I love you too we have to come clean
Mike and 11:00 you guys are our real OTP
you're clearly in love with each other
and honestly you guys are almost as cute
as will in his wizard costume and that's
saying a lot
so can you tell us again why you aren't
dating in real life it just doesn't make
any sense
but whatever we'll keep our fingers
crossed for the near future by the end
of this video you won't believe how many
stranger things actors look a lot
younger than they actually are and
you'll be shocked to find out which
co-stars actually fell in love on set
keep watching to get all the deets
Millie Bobby Brown Millie was born on
February 19th to 2004 making her 15
years old her on-screen character 11 is
dating Mike wheeler and they're totally
in love Millie and Victoria Beckham son
Romeo were rumoured to be dating last
year after Millie called it quits with
her ex-boyfriend Jacob Sartorius but as
of now it appears that Millie is 100%
single thin will heart although many of
us wish that Finn and Millie would
couple up already these co-stars are
just friends I like the new look by the
way it's called Finn was born on
December 23rd 2002 making him over a
year older than Millie he's 16 years old
and still considers himself to be a baby
boy which is why he doesn't have a
girlfriend right now
dacor Montgomery this Aussie actor has
quickly become one of the most
celebrated characters from stranger
things season 3 despite playing as
seventeen-year-old Baker is actually 24
years old and in case you were wondering
Baker is off the market he's dating his
longtime girlfriend lived [ __ ] who
comes from Dakers hometown of Perth
Australia these two make one gorgeous
couple datin Matarazzo move over suzy
and make way for lizzie you who is
gaytan's real-life girlfriend Jane and
Lizzie have been dating for over a year
now and they looked so happy accompany
each other to their junior prom in May
of 2019 Gaytan plays Dustin the adopted
14 year old son of Daddy Steve but in
reality Gaytan is actually 16 years old
Winona Ryder stranger things just
wouldn't be the same without the
puzzle-solving choice buyers she's
always up to something
be it decoding Christmas light messages
or solving the case of demagnetized
fridge magnets Winona Ryder is 47 years
old in real life and she's dating
fashion entrepreneur Scott McKinley
sorry hopper but you missed your chance
David Harbour well as it turns out david
harbors doing just fine without
Wynonna's love but the same can't be
said about chief hopper who is totally
hung up on choice the 44 year old actor
is currently dating Alison sudol who
plays Queenie in fantastic beasts and
where to find them we just can't get
enough of this power couple Jo Keary
although Steve Harrington might be 18
years old in season 3 of stranger things
jo curie is actually 27 years old and
we're sorry this burst your bubble but
daddy steve is off the market
jo is currently dating actress micah
monroe the couple keeps their
relationship on the down-low but they've
been dating since they met on the set of
after everything in 2017 Maya Hawk at
first fans believed Steve and Robin to
be a match made in scoops ahoy but that
cookie crumbled very quickly Maya Hawkes
characters about 18 years old which is
only a little younger than Maya's actual
age the 21 year old actress is currently
dating the president and CEO of winter
media the media company responsible for
founding Rolling Stone magazine Caleb
mcLaughlin
there is no one cuter than Lucas which
is why max quickly picked him out from
his friend group and made things
official but in real life the 17 year
old actor is actually single she's been
focusing on his acting career and it's
totally paying off we've got ourselves a
stick of dynamite but we're sure that
someone is gonna snag Caleb sooner than
later
Sadie sink Elevens best gal pal and
Lucas's on-screen girlfriend is none
other than max but in real life Caleb
and Sadie are strictly friends they get
along super well which is what makes
them an awesome on-screen couple Sadie
is 17 years old but still manages to
play fourteen-year-old max with ease
much like Caleb Sadie is single and Beau
seeing on her social life and career
know a snap if you are wondering who the
youngest og stranger things cast member
is it's none other than Noah snap this
adorable actor is only 14 years old he's
currently single but he's looking
forward to getting into a relationship
someday and according to him fans aren't
off-limits Noah is one of the few actors
who is of age with their on-screen
character believe it or not but there
were rumors that Noah and Milly were
dating a few years back but in the end
it was revealed that they are simply the
best of friends
Natalya Dyer and Charlie Hayden it's
always a dream come true when an
on-screen couple falls in love in real
life and this the case for Natalya Dyer
and Charlie Heaton the actors portray
Nancy and Jonathan worked constantly
looking danger in the eye improving
their bravery Natalya is 22 years old
while Charlie is 25 they met and fell in
love on the set of stranger things and
have been dating ever since
Natalya and Charlie valued their privacy
and have managed to maintain a low-key
relationship and that's a wrap on the
cast of stranger things real-life ages
and relationships before you go tell us
who your stranger things Oh TP is in the
comment section below don't forget to
give this video a big thumbs up and be
sure to subscribe to the things so you
never miss another video thanks for
watching we'll see you soon
[Music]